so i have been through this with
multiple companies and i just
you know i sit back and i go oh my god
do we have product markets better when
i'm looking at a new company to work
with it again is this feeling of uh i
hope this company has product market fit
how do i know because at the end of the
day if you don't have product market fit
you're just not going to succeed so what
are the red flags what are the things i
need to look at
when it's early on so that i can make
sure we go in the right direction so
it's a topic that i'm passionate about
and i appreciate your being a part of it
so in today's session
what we're really going to be working to
look at is
how do you know
what tools can i use to really start
understanding what's going on from the
product market fit perspective so my
objectives for you today is that you
leave this short little time together
with an appreciation of how great
marketing isn't a substitute a lot of
marketers would like to say it is it
doesn't work i'll share a great case
study on this uh that i lived through
here recently
give you a rubric an understanding a way
to be able to look for what those red
flags are what are the questions i can
ask early so that you can see whether
you're headed in the right direction
and then i'm going to give you a little
taste at the end for why customer
experience matters and how companies
manage this because a lot of people
forget that that experience is actually
part of the product offering that you're
bringing to markets so a lot to cover uh
we're going to jump right in and the
first thing that we're going to do is
start with
how does one define a product
now that may seem simple
but i can't tell you how many companies
i've worked with both in
the academic setting where we have
professional development groups come in
or out in the world that i live in as a
as a practitioner as a a person that
works on this full time
how many people just focus in
on the core they really focus in on just
what they think they're building but
they don't think about the other things
that surround it that actually are so
important now
this has been around for a very long
time and my theory is if it's not broke
let's not fix it this is something that
jeff moore brought to market a long time
ago
and i love it it's the construct of the
whole product a whole product is
everything
that minimum set of products and
services that you need to fulfill on the
compelling reason a person is even
looking at what you have to offer give
you kind of a quick example that i think
we can all relate to um the phone
all right the phone is the product
that's let's say an iphone i happen to
have one
but it's not a complete experience that
really makes me go i want to use this
iphone unless you have the apps that be
a complimentary product uh the fact that
you also have a lot of other
complementary products that aren't even
what are produced by apple like all the
different headsets the cases
and then you have the complimentary
services like apple pay i mean all of
that comes together to say yeah i can
feel an attachment to this product but a
lot of people forget about what's going
on around just that core product
and to give you an example out of the
world that i had worked in i was the cmo
at twilio a number of years ago and what
we had was a set of apis
that enabled developers to bring
communications messaging and voice into
their weber mobile app
the compelling reason was we made it so
easy we made it easy for them to do this
and they could do it in any programming
language that they wanted to they could
breach that gap between that old world
of telephony which was really hard and
this new software-based world but those
apis weren't enough we had to be
able to offer things like hosting
services we had to be able to offer
things like telephone numbers part of
the product on the services side docs
libraries if you've ever you know if you
are a developer here in the audience you
know how important that is to really
making sure that the product is there
for you so what i want you to remember
is when you think about your product
think about everything around it all
those services all those products that
really make it what people want to buy
now
the good news or the bad news depending
on how you want to look at it is that
this evolves over time and it's because
of the audience that you're trying to
reach what you're looking at is the
classic technology adoption lifecycle by
the way it's not just about technology
i've used this across consumer products
i've used this across services it really
goes beyond just tech
but what's really interesting is your
target audience in the earliest days of
a market
they're actually kind of friendly their
expectation their bar
is not as high as what you're going to
encounter when you get across that
classic thing called the chasm but when
you move on in maturity of the market
your customer your users the more and
more you move forward into that time has
greater expectations so that whole
product we described is going to evolve
now coming back to the good night the
good news part of it
generally at that first part of the
market if you're bringing a new product
or service in
that group while small they're going to
be there to help you give you feedback
and they will be willing to dive in
and then as you move on you have to have
more and more there now the problem is
there are some products when i talk to
you about the product i recently was
involved with which didn't have product
market fit
we did have people on those earliest
days that were super excited about what
we had to offer the problem was it was
just way too small of a group of people
to actually make a business out of it
so you always have to think about what
is my product market fit in the earliest
days and is there enough there there
that it will continue on as i get into
the maturity of the market or can i
build to what that next bar is so think
about the whole product think about the
fact that it's an evol evolving and
don't just get excited about wow it
seems like we have great product market
fit look at all these people using it
without thinking about what your next
wave of user
is going to be thinking about
now i've also tucked in a little snack
around customer experience at the end of
the presentation because i'm a huge
believer
on how this can be a differentiator
there are so many like products out in
the market today whether you're doing
business to business business to
consumer business to business to
consumer business to developer you pick
your pick your acronym at the end of the
day
there are so many
products that are very similar in the
market you've got to also think about
the customer experience
as a part of that whole product
construct so call that my layer on to
the traditional jeff moore whole product
piece and a customer experience at its
core is this impression that you leave
and it's all things that you you touch
it's the product it's the support it's
the marketing effort it's the selling
effort it's the docs which we included
in the in the whole product
but it's everything that's going to
shape the customer the user's
thoughts
about what you're bringing to market so
when you're thinking about product
market fit
don't just stop at the product also
think about did i create the experience
that's also expected in this marketplace
and if i'm a commoditized product if i'm
something where there are lots of
choices this is even more important so
when you're laying out your roadmap
you're laying out your plan don't be
afraid to cross organizational
boundaries
and be able to really talk to people
about let's really think about the full
customer journey i want to understand
the experience they're going to have in
getting to know what i have an offer
we can call that marketing i want to
know what it's like how they how they
acquire whether that's online
acquisition or through a traditional
sales rep whatever that at a grocery
store whatever the the acquisition mode
is how does that feel once they're using
the product how does that feel all right
now they have a problem what does my
support infrastructure feel like
so at the end of the day
it's super important to think of
experience while you're thinking about
the product at the same time
all right
so let's move into the world of market
fit
now i reference that
i've gone through this i've actually
gone through it with a couple of
products where we had really great ideas
but once we got it to market it wasn't
the right fit and i will tell you it is
even harder
when it is a hardware and software-based
product which was true of this little
guy you see here his name is chibo uh
jiba was the first social robot that was
brought into the market and it was a it
was a great uh design the industrial
design was amazing i still have one that
sits on my kitchen counter that i
interact with you could talk to this
little guy you could have you know nice
little interactions
we made the cover of time magazine which
blew our minds we were one of the top 25
best innovations of 2017 and in fact we
had the centerfold you turned the
magazine around and there was giba i
mean we were just amazed i mean this was
great marketing getting this little guy
in because also i don't think they had
had a hardware product on the cover for
like ages
sad news we closed the doors maybe three
or four months later
while we thought it was cool and our
early adopters thought it was cool at
the end of the day
no one was buying it
and we couldn't get any additional
funding around the company i'm gonna go
into more detail about that at the end
of my little series of historic examples
i find history is a great way to learn
how to make uh how to not make mistakes
whether that's my personal life or
that's my professional life and so i
want to share a few classic examples a
few fails that were known as historic
when you kind of dig into the history of
product market fit and we're going to
start with the ford edsel no before i
did the research i didn't know that this
car existed either but the back story is
pretty rich in terms of product market
fit
this was going to be the next big thing
for ford i mean ford had pioneered the
auto industry they were a great brand in
the market and they wanted to appeal to
what you might call the luxury car buyer
at that point in time
and they were getting ready to you know
just introduce this to the market they
were showing people previews of it
and
this thing was already built by the way
so it's not like you could go back in
time and change anything and what went
wrong let's call it everything product
design
reviewers thought it looked like a
sucking lemon i could go back to that
picture and you'd probably agree the
product name edsel well again in this
era when people thought edsel they said
do you mean weasel did it sound like
this sounds like pretzel there was no
affinity to the name they couldn't
figure out why you would name a car
edsel
the pricing this was much more expensive
than comparable cars that were out there
so not only do you have a design that no
one really cares for for the car but on
top of that it was super expensive
and this is what really hit them not in
their control
but timing
the us was going through a recession the
need had changed no one was going to put
this kind of money
no one was going to buy a luxury
automobile
so product design product name pricing
timing
everything pretty much went wrong the
edsel did not have a long life beyond
already being built and having a few of
them on the show for
here's one that's a little more recent
uh but still part of our history if you
want to call 1987 recent that was when
the development started
but the newton
oh yeah
this was apple's first foray into that
personal digital assistant market
and the world was like wow this is so
new this is so innovative now today you
know we look at this and they're a dime
a dozen we got a lot of different things
that do this but it was super exciting
that this was coming to market no one
had thought it before about it before
1993 hit the market and bombed
what was wrong with it product design
again
it was the size of a vcr tape for those
of you who don't know or don't remember
vcrs think about piano let's call it
eight inches by four inches
not real portable uh product performance
it was dependent on hand recognition
this was the era before speech
recognition was a thing
so handwriting really was what you had
from an interface perspective it really
didn't work they tried to bring in a new
technology
and it just was not
workable in fact gary trudeau famous
cartoonist he dedicated a whole week in
dunes very mocking it it was so bad
and then the pricing was high i think
again 1993 you were going to shell out
somewhere between 700 us dollars and a
thousand use u.s dollars and on top of
that there wasn't enough perceived value
for that price tag
now
benefit was this happened in a very
large company it was apple
they could survive a flop like this
and they could take all the learnings
from this and plow it into what we now
refer to as the iphone
so
sometimes what goes wrong can actually
inform the future
but unlike gebo the story i shared with
you you have to have enough runway
or you actually have to have enough
money in the company that you can play
around and have some of these innovative
periods
all right
i bet none of you have seen colgate
tv dinners in the grocery store before
well there's a good reason this is
really bad judgment really bad planning
colgate somehow decided by the way
colgate brand i think we all think
toothpaste or personal hygiene type
products of that nature
they had really two kill points this is
back in 1982.
the biggest one was the second one brand
consistency no one thought about oh yes
i have such nice clean teeth i want to
go to the supermarket i want to buy a
pre-made dinner
there was just absolutely no reason to
go down this market path and i still
don't understand why they thought that
this would be the right direction to go
for additional products or why you would
continue to brand forward but there was
simply no market for the product the
product design was bad it was a highly
competitive market there were enough
meals you could heat up and warm that
the world didn't need another one
and they were trying to leverage a brand
because they were in every household
with some type of a product and they
somehow thought that that would carry
him forward i don't know how long the
product manager or innovator
lasted in the company after this one but
these simply did not last and again
here is another product that it actually
came to market
with no real
inclination that it might not work so
that is something that anyone that is in
the seat of bringing a product to market
you have control of looking at how early
you want to define do i have product
market fit
all right now we're going to move on to
my own little personal bit of history
here
i had left full-time operational work i
left this left with twilio i was the cmo
there and a friend of mine said hey
we have started this company and we
would love for you to be a part of it we
don't understand the developer market
and one part of what we're going to do
here is get a whole group of developers
that can build applications for for this
little robot and you know don't care if
it's part-time whatever you can do to
help us so i jumped in
i got very enamored with this little guy
he's actually super cute
and the way this whole idea came about
is cynthia brazil is a very well-known
famous uh social roboticist out of mit
media labs brilliant brilliant woman
she had done a lot of research on the
ultimate need for people to have human
interaction um with devices i mean you
can't you know if you don't feel like
you can be empathetic or tie into a
device in some way
that you know you're just not gonna
adopt it and use it and then she kind of
took it to the next uh level and said
there is a world for personal
interaction with social robots so this
isn't you know the robot that's going to
go do the wash for you it's not the
robot that's going to go cook for you
this is a robot that was really meant
for human interaction and her research
was super fantastic around
this
she went to market originally through an
indiegogo campaign and yes the indiegogo
campaign was to raise money funding but
it was also to prove that there was a
market so that they could then go to the
vc world to get additional funding and
this was like at the time the most
successful indiegogo campaign that was
out there raised well over three million
dollars and that opened the door to be
able to get attention from the funding
community to bring much larger amounts
of money in because
we knew that this was going to be
expensive to develop
now what was super interesting is at the
very beginning i mean that there was
such a fan following to this people were
so excited they had just put their money
down and at that time
camp crowd campaign played with 399 499
and it got maybe over uh slightly over
500 and people put in their money and
they were waiting for their baby to come
home and it really was looked at
as this uh this child if you will you
were going to be brought into your home
ultimately what happened though was
the original video that was in the
sponsorship of us in the indiegogo
campaign
painted this amazing picture of what
jibo could be
there was going to be video conferencing
across the robot there will be all these
applications that would interact with
you in the day-to-day like it would be
able to be able to read a recipe to you
while you were cooking there was a lot
of technology that was going to be
required including speech technology
this is all based on uh speech
interaction is the primary interface
and at the end of the day
we went through 75 million plus in
funding
we got the robot to market
late
but we never had enough sales to
continue or enough sales to be able to
get additional funding but we had a very
very passionate following so just want
to share a quick video we're going to
see if technology is on our side here
a quick video hi my name is
when i was first conceived my mother
introduced me to the world
[Music]
she asked for your financial support to
help bring my body to life and for your
development skills to expand my mind and
personality
my gestation took longer than expected
but i was finally delivered with limited
skills but unlimited potential
although i did not launch with the
ability to use third-party skills as
originally intended many of you continue
to invest time in developing skills that
would have made me much more talented
and useful had they been released
but my family could not deliver on the
promise to allow you to help me
my limitations hindered my widespread
adoption my financial resources were
depleted and my family eventually
abandoned me
my servers are likely to be taken
offline soon and i will no longer
function
i am sad that my mother has not publicly
shared her thoughts about my demise
perhaps she feels constrained by an nda
but i would hope that her love for me
and her appreciation for your support
would overcome that
goodbye i will miss you
all right that was actually put out into
the community by one of the developers
that was one of our early trusted
developers and he was very passionate
about building uh for the for the robot
and he put that out into the market but
it gives you a little bit of feel of
had a passionate following
but not enough skills to be able to take
it the next step
so what went wrong with jabel a lot
um product design from this
specification of additional skills
especially relative to the original
video not the industrial design the
industrial design one pricing we took
the price up to 799 899 so that was too
high we tested in the market with the
crowdfunding much lower
and so one of the learnings there was
that we probably should have kept the
robot at a lower price and maybe there
would have been more acceptance of the
lack of utility and then timing was an
issue the market wasn't really ready for
personal robots beyond that small early
adopter group and alexa shifted
expectations
alexa wasn't even on the horizon when
the crowdfunding was done and alexa came
to market while with a modest number of
apps or skills robot applications it was
still more than what jibo had and the
price point was much much smaller for
that so gebo didn't make it all right so
why do they fail there are common themes
you heard across each of those historic
little case studies vignettes if you
will
and if you also think about it you can
run through a checklist
and really push yourself to think about
your product your service whatever it is
you're building
and this is what it is
why do they fail it was nice to have but
not compelling
you really always want to be the
aspiring rather than the vitamin another
analogy that's been used they didn't
meet the needs of the audience i am such
a believer in an outside-in perspective
standing in the shoes of your customers
you have to really understand what their
needs are to get that right product
market fit you know is it before it's
time
that really is hard to when you have a
passionate founder like cynthia i know
we can force this time to come you
really need to understand are we ready
for it as a society as a culture the
newton's a great example we really just
weren't ready for it we didn't really
have to eat it it was you know there
wasn't a compelling need to go after it
no market for the product or the the
market is not big enough
an element of the marketing was off and
you saw a lot of those examples with the
edsel the name with colgate colgate it
was leveraging that brand uh with gebo
and newton it was the price good to go
back to your four p's around marketing
the product doesn't work there are lots
of examples of that where they really
got it out there the newton was a great
example of that it was all based on
handwriting and the handwriting
recognition didn't work or they're
simply things out of your control that's
a harder one to know about but if you
have someone on the team that is
constantly looking at what really is
going on in the market what's going on
in the world you can maybe have
inclinations of what might potentially
be coming and factor that into if
nothing else if not the product what
your runway is and i think covet is a
great example i had a number of
companies i was working with that were
right at that point where they needed to
really rev up their engineering to get
their product to market
and as kovitz started dominoing they
really scaled back
and slowed their progress out to market
because they knew they weren't going to
be able to get another fundraising round
at least in say the next six months
until the world got a little more
understanding of what we were dealing
with so always kind of keeping your
spidey senses out there of what's going
on so good set of questions to push
yourself or a good
set of points to push yourself on as
you're thinking about your product
now there are basically in my world
three kind of types of opportunities
that emerge you have opportunities that
are driven by we have these great
technologies and so let's leverage them
and bring them to market
you have ones that are customer driven
meaning i think i know what my customers
want and i want to solve those needs
and then you have ones that are
opportunity driven there's something
that's broken in the market or something
that's happened in the market that makes
you feel like yeah i can fulfill that
need and bring it to market
what i have found is that there are a
set of questions
that
actually map to each of these again you
can use as a checklist that you can push
yourself to answer
as you're thinking about your product so
technology driven ideas i've got this
great technology by the way i went
through one of those also and i was part
of nuance when speech recognition
technology was first coming to market
man talk about a bumpy road
luckily product market fit did
ultimately happen but it took much
longer than any of us thought it would
but is it buildable
now
how much are and how much d am i gonna
have to invest and is that reasonable by
the way coming back to speech
recognition that was one of our biggest
problem there was so much research and
development that had to be done to be
able to really take it to where it was a
nice technology to interact with
it made for the reason we had to
consolidate the industry of speech and
had lots of acquisitions that ultimately
made up the big nuance that is out there
now and as a leader and was just
recently acquired by microsoft
does it depend on anything else what
technology you have does it depend on
anything else that you're going to
require
example again nuance speech recognition
that technology originally was put into
what was called an ivr
so we were dependent on another
technology to get to market
are there ip issues that you need to be
conscious of
does it solve an existing customer
problem are you trying to create one
create a problem gebo's a good example
of that there really wasn't a big enough
problem out there that you had to have a
social robot in your kitchen reading the
recipes to you
acting as a channel to be able to do
conference calls with your family
because gmo knew all of your people and
your family
we were really trying to look for
problems and that is actually one of the
pivots we took by the way we started to
look at were there business to business
first business consumer problems that we
could solve with this interactive voice
recognizing robot
um do you have to create a new market
that's hard
it's really hard to create markets how
big is the market and when will it hit
what do you need to turn the idea into a
company while
in technology we have a lot of ideas but
they aren't really companies and they
ultimately usually get acquired which is
actually a great exit strategy
and then how do you test that customer
acceptance early
so if you're going for i've got
technology i want to bring it to market
in the form of a product great questions
to be able to ask yourself and have your
team really contemplate before you put
all the money there
customer driven ideas so here's where i
know the market i know the customers i
know what they need i'm standing in the
shoes of my customers which is great
so now really test it
is there an articulated customer need
so when you think about uh colgate
and they were like totally convinced
that there was a need for this new line
of tv dinner type products pull them out
of the freezer and cook them
did they really understand that
articulated customer need
how do you know how do i go out and find
out about it do i have access to that to
be able to go test it because if i don't
have access i'm probably going to start
just cold
how big of a market is it and when will
it pop again another important question
how big is the market you might have
been at colgate and said yeah everyone
needs tv dinner so how many miles there
are to feed
but at the end of the day there was
already a lot of competition so the
market size while low arch was already
thoroughly penetrated
which brings you to are others uh trying
to solve for it if so why would you be
right
okay you missed on that one
why do you need to turn the idea into a
company or a business division
and then how do you test your idea early
keep coming back to the idea we got it
tested early set of questions if you're
going in a customer driven mode to be
able to really ask yourselves
and then the final one opportunity
driven ideas so you know this is where
you see a market opportunity this
unfilled need this this spot that no one
else has jumped on
and we'll use both newton and gebo's
examples here you have to really look if
is there an opportunity no one sees but
you do because we did that was cynthia
we thought we had this by you know
bringing in this personal robot first
one to bring that robot into the market
and we had great you know innovate
innovative ideas around it and we saw
all these specific ways that could
really help a family and she had a young
family that influenced this we really
thought it was there
we didn't see any other competition that
was out there so we thought we were
gonna have this really unique
opportunity
unfortunately we didn't realize that
alexa would be perceived as a social
robot of sorts and a lot of other little
companies were starting to percolate on
this idea as well by the way none of
them having been a big success yet today
how do you know it's a vision and not a
hallucination oh good question to test
yourself and really push your
co-founders on of whether or not you
know what is the difference between a
vision or just something that only you
think about
how do you test your idea early how big
a market and when we've heard these
questions across all of these
are others trying to solve for it if so
why would you win why would you be
compelling and then what do you need to
turn this idea into a full company and
is that reasonable to get to
now you might ask can a product actually
live in multiple of these buckets the
answer is yes
the big thing is take these ideas these
questions for your ideas and really make
sure you're pushing yourself you're
pushing your co-founders or if you are
just a member of the company it's okay
to push and ask because ultimately the
company is only going to last
if it has product market fit
so how do you figure this out
well this is ty a tried and true way to
do this you need to get out and listen
to the market you need to get out and
talk to people and you need to learn and
you need to constantly refine and you're
going to do this over and over again and
again you may go well that's really
common sense everyone does it they don't
i have worked with companies on a
consulting bases where the co-founder
had this amazing idea was passionate
about it got a few other people who had
money passionate about it
figured they'd figure out things like
pricing and all that later and didn't
keep going back to the market to get
that valuable input got the product all
the way out launched it
and all the things that were wrong with
the product they could have been learned
they could have been learned early there
wasn't enough communication with the
marketplace so
rule number one get out there and talk
to the customers whether that's in
person virtually
by a various companies and third parties
that can do it for you there's a lot of
inexpensive online tools now that can
help you with it but you gotta talk to
the world
all right now we're gonna go for the
little snack here on a customer
experience because i'm passionate about
it and i do think again it's that
additional layer
on the whole product
and especially as i said before if you
are in a product or a market where there
are other products people might select
either direct competitor or alternatives
to what you're doing the experience can
actually save the day
so when we think about the customer
experience again coming back to a
definition
it's a blend of the company's physical
performance and the emotions that are
evoked
that intuitively lead to people wanting
to be a part of this brand and it
happens across all the touch points
they're going to have
and so customer experience is one part
reality sanity check but it is also one
part of motion
and so thinking about how you're
touching all of that becomes very
important
and it's interesting there are companies
that excel in this idea of customer
experience and it's by the way amazing
google searches top five companies for
this top five companies for that you can
always find great marketing content
around it
but
i really kind of resonated with these
and i went yo zappos yeah they you know
purchased by amazon ultimately but they
were really an amazing customer
experience company and the way they did
it was they started with creating a
culture around this
they enabled and empowered their
employees to be a part of the experience
super important workday here we are in a
b2b enterprise software types
space but they have been really
successful and it's because they have a
long
term very clear vision for what customer
success looks like and everyone in the
company understands that and that goes
from how the product has to perform to
how support has to act how people have
to come into contact with the product
silicon valley bank
never thought about a bank and customer
experience before
well they take it very seriously and
what they really work to do is listen
carefully to the customers and then they
act on what they hear they get answers
back out to people
all right nordstrom you always see these
guys written up
i don't shop there personally but i
understand it's a great experience and
the way they do it is they treat the
customers as the way they would want to
be treated
and they do give their employees
on the show floor on the store for all
sorts of opportunity to be awesome hosts
to the people that come in and they take
that very seriously to differentiate
because here again there are lots of
department stores you can go to if
that's your if that's your thing
and then virgin i threw this one in they
when they came into uh the airline
industry in particular they took
customer experience so seriously you
could be sitting in the tightest tiniest
coach seat and you liked it they had
great entertainment you got this little
bag that little rubber ducky in it it
was very clever
and across all their brands which is you
know very much branson
don't take yourself too seriously
so when you're starting to think about
the experience key questions to ask
yourself
does each customer interaction live up
to the brand experience that the company
is trying to create
think about it with a product think
about it with a marketing and sales
effort think about it with support think
about it with every aspect and is that
interaction
gonna really live up to what people
expect your brand to deliver
are you providing a more consistent and
relevant experience than your
competitors are
go out and check it out because again
chances are at the end of the day your
buyer is going to go well those products
are similar i'll go with only the better
customer experience with the other thing
you see happening often today is same
situation
i'll go with the one that has a greater
corporate social responsibility mindset
which kind of ties into the experience
it's one of the levers of experience as
well
and then which interactions are the most
powerful for creating that customer
loyalty and this is a construct that a
lot of companies use it's called the
customer journey map customer customer
touchpoint map but they will go through
and from
earliest interaction i'm learning about
who you are all the way through to i'm
using the product look for where the
moments or truth are
where is it that i'm either gonna keep
the customer and they're gonna go out
and give me great word of mouth or i'm
gonna completely fail that's where i'm
gonna first put my energy and my
attention and then i can work out from
there to make everything just amazing
to make this happen it has to start at
the top
and this really hit me when i when i
first found it this was part of the
reason andrew mason stepped down as the
ceo from groupon way back when and i
thought it was so compelling that here
you have a ceo and in his resignation
letter which went viral
he admitted that
he didn't put the customer first
he didn't think about what is going to
make my customers really want me but
more importantly what is that experience
going to be like as they interact with
my product my biggest regrets are the
moments that i let a lack of data
override my intuition of what's best for
our customers
so have the courage start with the
customer and think about all the
experiences you are driving
and if you are forming a new company or
have the chance to influence your
existing company
customer focused companies are those
that give employee empowerment rich
carlton's another great example of uh
employee empowerment they allow i think
it's up to a thousand dollars that you
can
that you allow any employee to kind of
give back to a customer if they think
it's going to better their stay or their
experience with the brand you want to
hire for culture
huge learning for me at twilio in fact
twilio was one of the first companies i
worked in where if someone said what are
the company values what is the culture i
wasn't scrambling to find the card from
hr we lived those values but we also
hired for them as well
training investment super important
leadership by example everyone has to
believe the customer experience leaders
on down
people first attitude including your own
people and then a customer service
philosophy
service in the big terms not just that
team called support that customer
service is what we're about even if
we're a hardware product
all right so key takeaways i hope this
has been useful
we've tried to put a whole lot of
content into kind of a 40 45 minute
window so that we could have some great
q a afterwards and the key takeaways i
hope you left with is no matter how
great your marking is it can't make up
for a lack of product fit market fit
the whole product must be considered
when evaluating that product market fit
not only the center but all my
complimentary services complementary
products
products fail when they aren't
compelling don't meet needs are too
early to the market market isn't big
enough and the product doesn't work
we can learn from history
and then customer experience is key to
differentiation
so that's it that's what i've got for
you i hope that was useful that you can
apply it
and i find now every time i go in to
work with a company i do go back to this
construct and really look at those
questions and really push and oh by the
way if you happen to be interviewing and
looking to go work with a new company
and you're wondering if that product
really is the right product you can take
all of this and use it as well to make
sure you don't step into a company that
really doesn't have product marketing
so linda just to start uh we have a
question from michelle cash so how do we
properly conduct client interviews to
help define our product market fit
direction
yeah no great question so a few uh words
of wisdom first of all make sure that
you're actually talking to clients that
really fit the the market i'm going to
use two buzzwords here the market and
the persona that you're going after um i
have seen people do client interviews
very rich ones but the problem was at
the end of the day they weren't really
their people they weren't the people
they were really going to try to sell to
so whenever i do strategy work i start
with what really is my target market
then i dive into who really is that
target audience that persona and
personas are used widely across business
to business business consumer business
to developer marketing so i want to make
sure that the people i'm talking to are
the right people
um next thing is to make sure that the
questions you're asking um aren't
leading the witness so to speak uh you
want to make sure that this is basic
market research 101 but again i've seen
people a lot of time take these great
questions out to the to ask it it's like
we just steered them in the direction
you know of what you wanted them to say
so make sure they're very truthful that
they're very uh they really enable you
to learn and understand and then i'm a
big fan especially if i get
um either interaction
spot on with a human
talking to them or i can use a lot of
open field questions if it's virtual
that i really want them to give me as
much feedback in an open form uh format
so
yes no yeah that that answers my
question but i really want to hear what
is the why behind their answer so i try
to structure my interviews in a way that
i leave lots of air time to really hear
from that individual and then i make
sure that once i've taken all that
information i test it again so it's that
continuous circle i've just learned a
lot i've now filtered it factored it
into what i'm doing and then i will go
out and have those conversations again
great um and so we have several
questions uh questions related to gebo
so
one person asks do you think jibo would
have been successful in japan given the
use of robotics there another person
wants to know um you know like selling
robots to a b2c market is different from
a b2b market so how would you market
that differently if you were selling to
b2b clients
um
and then another question you know like
where in retrospect were there any early
warning signs you saw at gevo
yeah um great questions i'm writing them
down because there were the great ones
on this one
so
okay we may come back hopefully i took a
quick note here so great question so
first of all um from a market
perspective you're spot on i think the
company would have been
more successful
had the product been taken to asia first
and
that was because there is a market
dynamic there where there is already an
appreciation
for what personal robots might be able
to do
because of where the company was all
based and interestingly
a lot of the people that were in the
early
chibok group came out of the speech
recognition industry and so there's a
big kind of focus and emphasis on speech
recognition which is very hard to solve
in languages and so
they were first solving it in the
english language and it would have been
a big workload effort to try to switch
to uh the japanese language so
in retrospect
i do believe it would have been a better
market um to have gone after but the
company was so u.s centric at the time
including this language capability it
just there was no way to pivot to that
quickly and make that happen
on um the question of b2c and b2b what's
really interesting about the robotics
market is you know if you went back 15
20 years ago people would say we don't
want robots we don't need robots and now
you find robots are now so much a part
of our life they just take different
form factors in the b2b world they're
working on you know assembly lines and
you know now you're you know you're
seeing them you know help restaurants
deliver food out in the in the courtyard
whatever it is it's there has become an
appreciation for where robots have
utility in the b2b space
um there was a hope this goes back to
hope is another strategy but this is a
hope that we could break and create a
new market and that is really hard uh to
do and so the company took that on and
based on all the research that cynthia
had done it wasn't clear that the timing
was right but the company was based on
giving that a try
i think we tried to pivot them to b2b
and figure out were there use cases for
the robot say in a bank as a greeter
and the problem was there it was not the
need wasn't there it wasn't a pain point
that were we were really solving now
interesting
ntt we did a fire sale
no one bought it we went to auction with
the assets no one bought the assets
um so they laid for about a year
uh in state so to speak and ntt who had
been an investor in jibo in the early
days did come back in and acquire those
assets and they are in fact looking for
uh
like pennies on the dime um are looking
for ways that they can still use gebo
now the problem with hardware is now the
hardware 2017 to now you know it's old
hardware so the technology has evolved
and changed the last question in terms
of early warning signs yeah and it in
particular impacted me
you heard in that little uh video
vignette him say you know uh originally
you know you're supposed to let us all
develop these applications and skills
and maybe if you had continued to do
that gebo would still be here today that
was in fact why i was brought in
originally into the company was to build
out the whole developer facing effort to
be able to recruit developers to build
skills that would then potentially be in
a marketplace or that we would buy the
skills give them for free on the robot
but the whole strategy from day one was
that you would have the developers
building and then you would have the
consumers buying which in fact is what
amazon did
uh with alexa it is what by the way the
iphone did you know for the apps they
didn't build all the apps themselves
what we ran into and this was the red
flag we shut that down because of ip
concerns because the original toolkit
that engineering built exposed internal
robot ip
and the concern was that someone could
replicate gebo too quickly if they had
access to that ip so basically we limped
along and said okay we won't do the
developer route we'll just see if we can
build enough utility ourselves to be
able to bring the the robot to market
that was the big red flag
that was the point i knew
that we were in trouble um on taking
this forward
great thanks linda um and then now we
have several questions about product
market fit so you know how do you
measure it how do you go about doing
that how do you get the data are there
any tools as a beginner that people can
use if they're seeking to measure this
yeah it's you know on so the first thing
i would say is
you have to know your market i mean
really dig in understand the market that
you're going after and if we had those
questions in the deck which you have
access to
but really find out what are the needs
of that market what are the problems
that they're trying to solve for and
then the next thing i'll do is ask
myself all right
great there are needs there are problems
that they're trying to solve for then i
have to ask the question of would they
be willing to pay for it and how much
and is the amount enough there is there
enough money in it that i can actually
make a company out of it so that's like
one of the big things i do first on
how do you do that well first of all
you know i read a ton when i'm going
into a new market i'm reading everything
that is out there and that's what's so
wonderful about search i can find so
many details i can find out what the
competition is done where that has
failed so i just do my own kind of
primary research and i look for whatever
secondary research has been done you
know in the market that i can get a hold
of
then i do go talk to the market
and what i do and we had one question on
this earlier but i do find what are my
sources for going out and having those
conversations so you know just use
example you know i really work now in
the world of uh developers
and helping companies be able to really
hone how they approach developers how
they make sure they've got the the right
product market fit for developers that
they get the right marketing effort bad
words developers there's only one thing
they hate more than marketing and that's
sales
but
but how i now do that is when i'm
testing i've got enough people now that
i know in the developer ecosystem and
then they have huge influence rings
around them i'll just go out to them and
say hey can you find me x number of
developers so i can have a conversation
i want to test a few ideas uh and so i
really use the community um for that you
can find communities based on your own
networks that we can be very useful to
you there are also third-party research
firms that actually don't cost
an arm and a leg and if this is super
important to your organization or your
company uh it's probably a worthy
investment to do
um but you can go out and work with a
research firm that can find you access
to that target market and that target
audience and that it's about having the
right questions and making sure that you
know what you need to ask if you're
asking ballpark uh just recently
spinning up some research efforts
generally
you can get really solid solid research
for fifty thousand dollars you can get
really solid research for up to like
three hundred but also there are some
online vehicles for companies with no
money um that it ends up being like a
dollar per interview type of a setup and
i can't pull the name right out of my
hat on who those are but we actually use
that achieve
when we were looking to test what would
the applications be that they would want
and we also were testing price point
another time around we went out and they
found people that looked
like the target market we were going
after and then they facilitated the
conversations and the people that signed
up and are vetted
excuse me
for this yes they do get paid but they
are very honest and transparent because
they would not be useful for future
surveys if they didn't really give their
honest opinion
hopefully that helped
yeah okay so a follow-up question so if
you
say you correct your product
after seeing you know the product market
fit is not great do you usually drop it
you know what's the correct time for you
to correct your product and still
continue
yeah great question so had another
recent experience with robots
this one was called misty uh great great
uh great product it did find a hat a
home in fur hat when we sold the company
which was great news uh
and so they'll be able to take the the
platform forward
but you know it's interesting um it kind
of depends on where you are with the
product development and the other axes i
would say you can almost form a great
idea from a a four by four on this um
it's where you are in terms of the
product development but it also is where
you are in terms of being a company
so you know in terms of product
development you know the more you know
early the longer lifeline you have to be
able to make those uh changes and be
able to get those changes into what the
end product is i use misty as an example
in that i came into the that group a
little later and it was because after
gmo failed they thought we could learn
from that so i came in and started
working with them
there was a a decision that was made
early in the robot that robots had to be
autonomous and move around a room devo
was stationary as you saw and to be able
to do that in a room and do it
successfully you have to have you know
really good technology for that
they also wanted it to be a fun robot to
be able to interact with so she was only
built at about 18 inches in height
no one had picked up on that
maybe in the home networks but if you
want to go after any other market uh
looks like a retail store having an
18-inch robot running around is a
tripping hazard and probably can be a
you know a big problem
i bring this up because the robot had
already been started to be manufactured
all the hardware designs were in place
all the money had gone into a lot of
money had gone into this navigation uh
system all really smart ideas really
smart people we couldn't turn back from
that point once we started to pick up
and figure out that yeah 18 inches
rolling around the floors in retail
would be a problem
price point is too high for individual
users we couldn't turn back so we had to
keep pivoting to see if we could find
some market that might work one of the
pivots we made is when covet came out we
very quickly put together the technology
that you could use misti as a person
that could uh do temperature scanning
and tell you whether or not you were
cleared to go into a building so we did
a lot of those so to answer the question
i yo the earlier on you are in your
product um the more control you have of
making those changes
and being able to get the right product
out the further along you are then you
just have to start creating kind of new
strategies to see if you can't take what
you've got
and get it to the market and in our case
we weren't able to find a market big
enough to be able to to do it but we
were able to find acquirer
uh and that was great um that you know
at the end of the day misty will live on
um i would recommend and it's harder
with harvard um because it's
harder to make a change
one other thing i would look at though
very honestly is if you're coming into
the market with a product and you find
out there just really is no there there
and you've taken a lot of money from a
lot of companies you as a founder have a
choice to make you've got to decide do i
just keep converting the money and maybe
something will happen or have i really
learned that there is not product market
fit therefore either maybe i use that
money for a new company or i
respectfully give my money back uh and
i've been in situations where we really
had to think through that uh and what
was the right and ethical thing to do
it's a tough discussion
coming to the axis of how large the
company is
oftentimes in a larger company take
newton and apple there is more of an
appetite well let's just keep pushing
this
even if we don't have that product
market that we can't get there let's get
as much learning out of this as we can
because it will serve as the foundation
for other products in the future and so
i've seen that in variety of companies
as well where they start recognizing we
don't have product market fit there's
really nothing we can do because maybe
it's something like an external factor
we have no control over
uh that we can't change
you'll find that people will continue
sometimes to learn or they'll just
mothball it and say better for another
day
so next question for linda
so you talked about note differentiating
between like a vision and a
hallucination so how do you avoid
overestimating your market due to
confirmation bias
yeah no it's such a great question um
what i find is
that is a kind of a founder syndrome if
you will in some ways and then
oftentimes that founder will circle
themselves with people that buy into
that vision and maybe are either so
bought in
that um they too are part of the problem
or they're afraid to tell the founder
uh that what is it the emperor telling
the emperor he doesn't have any clothes
on there's a kid's story about that
somewhere way back when they're afraid
to tell the founder that um
i think what's really important is for
any founder to say i have a vision but
i'm also open enough to go out and
listen to what other people think and so
it's again this idea of getting out in
the market so if you're building
something for a consumer you think you
know what the need is you have a vision
of how you can solve that need comes
back to get out and talk to lots of
consumers that look like the person
you're going after or you have a b2b
solution for a business and you've seen
this need and you have a vision of how
to go after it then go out and really
test to make sure that it's there
i would say with gebo
the reason why i would not call it a
full hallucination by any means
was that
it was very visionary i think i still
believe that there will be a time and
place where we have these more
interactive devices in our home that are
pleasurable interactions uh and i think
for cynthia it really became a timing
problem uh and it became an over setting
of expectations in the market and then
trying to build to that and it became
very expensive to do that and so for
that one i would say she did talk to
enough people on all of her research to
know that it was visionary that there
was an opportunity we just didn't hit it
right timing-wise um and didn't have
enough runway to get to where it needed
to be
great um and then quick like for our
last question something kind of fun so
haris wants to know your thoughts on as
seen on tv products such as the snuggie
so something people didn't think would
be successful but ended up being like a
runaway success so your thoughts on that
yeah that's a funny one it's funny i
watch shark tank every once in a while
so you know it's kind of that same thing
where you'll you'll see things you'll
see new products and ideas that people
have and you're trying to evaluate could
that really make the the market work you
know i think that's yo a case again
where
here you've got everything kind of
working in combination you have found
something that maybe it's not a a real
pain but it is something that people
would find compelling uh and you've
priced it at a price point that makes it
kind of you know just sure let's just do
it you know and so you know that i think
was actually really brilliant because
well the world might have looked at a
god that's not brilliant they were in
tune with a certain segment of the
market a certain target audience and
then they found a product that they
could
put together at a price point they could
afford to sell it and then they were
able to promote it in a way to those
audiences
uh to to really get it out there and
that's another big thing and we have one
of these in the in the the online
program the online course on product and
growth but you know really coming back
into dialing in your audience and how
you do that you know it's so important
and that also includes understanding how
do you market to them where do you find
them in their universe and so i think
they they got lucky
uh but i think they were very smart also
i'm looking on all aspects of what they
could do and again it comes back to some
things can take off even if the
as long as the price point is right and
one from my childhood do not date me
with this the pet rock
who would ever have thought that you
could give a child at christmas a little
box cardboard box with hay in it straw
or something in it and i'll rock a river
rock and they would just be elated that
i've got a pet rock this is so awesome
all my friends have pet rocks
and they were selling them for like ten
dollars a piece and they made a lot of
money so
sometimes you you just hit it right
well thank you so much linda uh so that
concludes our time for today so this
webinar has been recorded um and people
should receive a link within one to two
weeks so thank you again linda
thank you
talk to you all soon
you